(cheers and applause)
- Sit down,
I know you're excited.
- Oh my god.
I love you so much.
- [Josh] Oh my god,
I love YOU so much.
- [Grace] Oh my god, your voice.
- I was telling you she loves you.
- So iconic.
- These are real tears.
Oh, no!
- She loves you.
I'm telling you.
- Oh my god.
- Oh!
- [Kelly] Can I tell you my favorite part?
'Cause I was reading her pre-interview,
and like all the things,
like, I've seen you in "Book of Mormon",
I've seen you in "Frozen"
or heard you in "Frozen."
All the things that you've done.
Tell him the one you mentioned.
- Bear claw!
- [Josh] - [Kelly] Bear claw!
- Bear claw from "New Girl",
that's her pull.
- [Grace] (singing) "Because
you're just a tree!"
- I also love "Wedding Ringer"!
- Oh, thank you.
You're too young to see that, but okay.
(laughs)
- [Grace] Shaking.
- You are so unbelievably talented.
- Thank you.
- We were listening to your
song in the car this morning.
"I Don't Know My Name"
and I'm blown away by you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] She's so talented.
- I'm blown away by you.
- You are mesmerizing.
Really incredible.
- Thank you.
I love that you're crying,
it's so cool.
- I'm not crying,
I'm fine.
- Never lose that though.
- It was the initial shock.
It was the initial shock.
- You shouldn't lose that though.
I think it's cool when you get so excited
about meeting people.
I'm 37 years old and I still,
ask Meryl Streep.
I look like an idiot.
(laughs)
Whatever, I don't care.
I like her.
- Mine was Harrison Ford.
Imagine how that went.
- Oh my god, was he quiet?
I feel like he would've been quiet.
- I literally was like,
"I love you."
And he's like, "All right."
(laughs)
- So why bear claw?
Why was that your pull?
- I love "New Girl".
I actually just did an
interview with Zooey Deschanel.
- Oh, I love Zooey.
- 'Cause I'm like a
diehard "New Girl" fan.
But they told me on the phone,
they were like,
"Okay, so someone's gonna be
sitting with you on the couch."
And I'm like, "Oh, okay."
And so,
they were like,
"Oh."
I was like, "Who is it?"
And they were like, "Josh Gad."
I was like, "Who's that?"
So I didn't know who that was.
But I'm like a huge fan.
But I know you as Bear Claw.
- There are so many emotions
that I'm going through right now.
(laughs)
- [Grace] Me too!
- Didn't know who you were,
then when I learned who you were, I cried.
- I cried really hard on the phone.
- No, I know what you mean though
'cause I don't ever know
everybody's real name sometimes.
- Especially actors.
- I don't know actor's names.
- I'm the same way.
- Yeah, and I always think
that they're the person
they were in the movie,
and they're not.
- [Grace] Oh.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- We're celebrating Thanksgiving though,
so what are you thankful for this year?
- Happy Thanksgiving.
(cheers and applause)
- What are you thankful for this year?
- My family, of course.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I'm very thankful for my family.
They're very strong.
- I hear you're making
a special dish, though,
this Thanksgiving, right?
- Yes!
Oh my god.
Okay, so I just learned,
well not just,
I've been learning how to cook
because I don't know,
I just really wanted to be like,
that girl, just like,
cooking, listening to music,
like I don't even care,
messy bun, so.
- By the way, I love
people who cook like this.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Just get in there, Josh.
- [Grace] Well, that's
my dream on how to cook.
So that's the goal.
- Got it.
- I'm working to get there.
- Oh.
- Oh, great!
Oh, okay!
- Thank you, Kevin.
- Thank you very much, Kevin.
- What's this?
- Don't look at it!
- I'm not!
- I'm not done.
- Totally not.
(laughs)
- I'm learning how to cook.
- Is this mine?
- I listen.
- I listen to my guests.
- That's my water, by the way.
(laughs)
It's all right.
- [Grace] I'm really happy.
- This is going so well.
So what is it?
- Lasagna soup.
- It's lasagna soup?
- [Josh] Lasagna soup.
- I've never heard of lasagna soup.
- It's lasagna made into a soup.
- Okay, wait, so can I look at it now?
- [Grace] Yes.
- Okay.
- Did you just play a game of
"Mad Libs" and were like...
- Yes.
- So, it's from last night,
and I don't know how they prepared it.
- [Kelly] - [Josh] Okay.
- It used to be in
Ziploc tupperware bowls.
- They?
What happened to you in the
kitchen with your dance moves?
- [Grace] I was in the kitchen.
- I mean, here's the thing,
- [Grace] Is it good?
- Yeah, it's really good, but like...
- [Grace] Imagine if like-
- [Kelly] So what makes it soup?
- Oh!
A lot of people ask me that.
- So this is called pasta.
(laughs)
- [Grace] Well, no, it's
'cause I do it wrong.
- I love you!
- So wait, we did it wrong.
- I do it incorrectly,
but that's what now makes it my secret.
So it's supposed to be soup,
but I always do it
perfectly every single time,
and it ends up like that.
I don't know why.
- I love you, Grace!
You're officially my favorite!
Sorry.
- Fair enough.
I've heard a lot of that today.
- Don't disrespect Josh Gad like that.
- I'm just kidding.
- Josh Gad is God.
- Just kidding.
You're only 15 though,
and you just finished
your second EP, right?
- I released one EP.
- And this is your second?
- Volume one.
- Yeah.
- So then there will be a volume two.
- Oh, okay.
This is "Letters", right?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- So wait, I'm excited for you.
You're actually acting, right?
In the Disney+ (mumbles).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, "Stargirl".
What is that about?
- It's about this girl named Stargirl,
who was homeschooled and
then goes to a public school.
- So were you nervous to act?
I hate acting.
- You do?
- Absolutely, 100%.
- Haven't I seen you in something?
- Yes.
(laughs)
We're not talking about one.
No.
(cheers and applause)
Two words.
Two words, America.
Contractually obligated.
I was on that damn show,
and they made me do that
beach blanket movie.
I did not want to do it.
I cried,
I couldn't get out of it.
I hate acting.
- Oh, that's the tea.
- I love actors.
I think that it's such a gift.
That's why I freaked out over (crosstalk).
- They have to be so talented.
I gained respect and I
lost respect for actors.
(laughs)
- You are my favorite guest ever.
So what is gained and lost?
- Could I possibly get
a water at some point?
(laughs)
- I don't think she drank from this one.
- I'll wait.
- I'm (mumbles).
- What did you gain and lose?
Like, what do you mean?
- Okay, so it's like,
okay,
so it's not as much work as
I thought it was gonna be.
It's so fun.
It's really...
You go to set,
I don't know if I just
had a weird experience,
you can tell me,
but I literally went to set,
there was just tons of catering,
read your lines,
and hang out with the cast.
- You had a weird experience.
(laughs)
- I had a special experience.
- I'm fascinated by how
advanced you are for your age.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, how are you so mature?
- I can't believe I'm
talking to you right now.
(laughs)
It's so incredible.
- Five minutes ago,
you didn't know who I was and were crying.
- I don't know.
I'm the youngest.
- Were you always,
how many siblings do you have?
- I have two siblings.
And my one sister is 18,
and my other brother is 20,
so I have always been like this
'cause I kind of followed their age gap.
- We have kids.
Some of your kids are
a little more advanced
than the others.
(laughs)
- None of my kids talk this way.
I'm gonna make them watch
this interview and be like,
"Do that."